robert spencer you've written a couple
of dozen books on islam which of those
books would you recommend to our viewers
to get the best introduction
to your thoughts on islam and sharia
well in the first place there's the new
one the critical quran which is an
honest translation of the quran a guide
to how muslims understand the quran and
an indication of the verses that are
most problematic for
non-muslim societies also then there is
the truth about muhammad which is a
biography of muhammad according to the
earliest islamic sources so between
those two you have the quran and
muhammad and
those are the two sources for islamic
law so that will give you a general
introduction to what is so problematic
about islam i also want to recommend my
book the history of jihad which is the
only book like it in the world the only
one volume history of the entire
phenomenon of jihad from the beginning
in muhammad's time or in the origins of
islam to the present day it is the only
book on jihad that covers not only the
jihad against europe which has been
covered in other books but the jihad
against india and the jihad elsewhere
around the world and that is a story
that most people are unfamiliar with as
a matter of fact even people who uh take
on islamic apologists in the west
generally they know about the koran and
they know about muhammad but they don't
know the history of islam and so the
history of jihad fills that gap